how is it different in in that I go
through my daily life I feel that the
world is teeming with life I mean I I
feel connected all the things you're
describing I feel that in my ordinary
day-to-day life you describe the sense
of going deeper or thinking more
philosophically and I don't so I don't
have experience of the mushrooms but I
think I've I read a book and I think
more philosophically where I look at a
work of art what was different about the
all of that on the mushrooms I don't
know if I could say it was more of it
slowed everything down and made me more
like it was like oh look at this water
like and you notice every little bubble
it just like made you so appreciative of
the moment pulled me into the moment in
such a way where I appreciated things I
never appreciated before